con un llamado al boicot de productos
franceses recep tayip erdogán se sumó a
las reclamaciones hechas desde diversos
países de la órbita musulmana para
condenar las políticas francesas contra
el islamismo radical
se ha dicho en francia que no compren
productos con etiqueta turca yo hago un
llamado a mi gente no den crédito a los
productos con etiqueta francesa no los
compren
bullard sóftbol las críticas del
presidente turco hacia emanuel macrón
han sido severas y ha llegado a
calificar la islamofobia como una peste
que se extiende por europa
los musulmanes están ahora sujetos a una
campaña de linchamiento similar a la de
los judíos en europa antes de la segunda
guerra mundial
en libia se ha visto a varias personas
pisotear la bandera francesa y quemarla
y en otros países como bangladesh los
fieles salieron a las calles para
criticar la actuación del jefe del
estado francés una protesta que ha
llegado hasta los supermercados de
jordania donde los productos franceses
ya fueron precintados una situación
preocupante que el líder de los
empresarios franceses ha catalogado de
chantaje el boicot a los productos
franceses es un chantaje al que no
debemos ceder apoyamos a las empresas
pactadas la polémica en torno al
mandatario francés surgió luego de que
francia decidiera endurecer sus leyes
contra el extremismo islámico y de qué
macrón defendiera la publicación de
caricaturas de mahoma
las tensiones se dan en momentos en los
que el país aún no se recupera del
trauma causado por la decapitación del
profesor samuel para ti a las afueras de
parís justamente por haber mostrado los
dibujos del profeta a sus alumnos